une production du studio sfr ou y est
c'est parti
bonne année mon ph n êtes pas de tuer le
clip de julien lacroix puis yannick de
martino qui répond à des questions c'est
tellement drôle de ce genre iris c'est
quand même moi je pense que c'est plus
une gangue fondé des vidéos sourreil sur
youtube il ya comme un mur rempli deux
enveloppes à des questions plus ils vont
en plus jeune quand pis les pauses et
c'est drôle
tabarnak céderait ses deux doute très
drôles ces deux drôles ces deux très
drôle hein mais c'est vrai que je t'aime
[Rires]
c'est gênant c'est vrai qu'en si jamais
tu sais on n'est pas que la foi qu'on a
été le plus proche c'est quand que je
t'ai vu tu t'en sors pas douter parce
qu'on n'est pas très tactile sinon mène
on est pauvre on serre pas la main
dessus
est ce que tu es tactile dans ta vie
jusqu'en tactile mais vu qu'on se
connaît depuis tellement longtemps d'une
époque où est ce que tu aimes moins
habituel détective ya comme un policier
jamais eu le step ou est ce qu on a
passé deux camps se regardent et dirigea
y est à comme se serrait la main puis un
jour c'est à dire salut comme le monde
le fait que l' on arrive dans nos parts
et genre de avec notre gagne secondaire
ou même des becs qui dit pas il m'a tout
le monde dont on joue en fait qu'on y
est on est tellement forget andrée
relation genre secondaire quelqu un de
nos interactions sont encore à ce niveau
là où tous ses comparses est ce que vous
y aussi ces grecs aussi et oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce que
pourquoi on est juste nous deux ben
pourquoi pas ben pourquoi pas en fait de
podcasts ont semblé comme hôpitaux appui
et de la coupole en fermant les gt2
exact c'est ça sent le 31 décembre
ce que vous allez entendre c'est pour le
nouvel an avec concision offert juste
nous deux on va se parler dans le blanc
des yeux on va se dire les quatre
vérités
j'ai jamais aimé puis spi s'arrête ce s
arrête ça pendant l'épisode nouvelles
infections on espère que si vous êtes là
c'est parce que vous aidez les fans du
sans fil puis et puis que vous passez
votre nouvel an ou peut-être que vous
l'écoutez 1er ou 2 ou 3 janvier il mais
dans tous les cas merci d'être là merci
d'être les amis de passage de l'année ph
j'ai passé une année mouvementée
augmenté j'ai bossé jusqu'à lui non plus
lorsque j'ai jamais été mais passer une
année mouvementée mais j'ai passé une
année extrêmement chargé jamais été
autant occupé de ma vie ça c'est sûr
c'est vrai ça c'est sûr et certain
j'étais sur un million d'affaires en
même temps j'ai jamais même penser ma
vie avoir une business puis dans les six
derniers mois je m'en suis parti deux
dont le studio ici même si des affaires
qui sont compliquées quand même qu'on
entreprenne toutes les affaires des
d'incorporation même pis les lettrines
mardi les employés m'insulte pour passer
les entrevues dira du monde qui sont
parvenus ouais semaine j'aurais jamais
pensé faire seul à recevoir du monde
entrevue puis un crayon email en dix ans
après ce et sorry bros vraiment merci
d'avoir pris ton tenté mais ont rendu
notre direction menacé d affaires qui
paye sa conscience car mon site quoi
mène tu le fait très bien
mais merci pauvres et se faire des
cheveux par exemple ces problématiques
et stressant c'est ça c'est stressant
mais c'est dur de trouver bâtisse on n'a
pas de temps pour trouver un bon
équilibre de vie
mais je trouve vraiment que tu mets
tout semble vraiment bien géré le stress
ou du moins de stress tu pars à l'ispo
what is back est moi ça m'arrive de
faire des journées où est ce que le
stress tellement grand que tu cherches
dans le déni total pour fériés ouais que
je reste dans mon lit ça t'arrive tu
mets ton dans des projets dernièrement
sa pas derrière même dans la dernière
année mettons pas ce qu'on fait la
rétrospective l'année sept étaient
arrivés dès justement des moments de
même moi ce qu'il y avait comme tout
match à fond à fond
ça m'est arrivé hier au moins non mais
ça m'arrive ça m'arrive ça m'est arrivé
mais il ya ce qui t'arrive vise pas que
j'en avais tout match c'était juste des
x men juste pris par jean riaj mais je
me disais je tendais pression je suis en
dépression avant d'arriver ici parce
qu'on s'est vus sur celui-ci s'est
agrandi la médée journée s'était passée
quand le matin de poche puis après ceux
qui commencent à travailler dans de quoi
ça marchait pas ça avant cette pause ces
journées là tu veux produire non plus
jeter la fin de la journée juste avant
de revenir au studio plus à mes
coordonnées inquiété puis c'est ce qui
s'était passé de quoi se plaint
personnels de poche j'ai cette résidente
quoi ça marchait pas ce n'est pas mon
goût c'est poche je suis retourné dans
mon email j'ai dormi
puis georges était merde alors ouais ça
m'arrive ça m'arrive de temps en temps
cette offre
moi j'avoue que ce ça m'arrive pas
mettons d'arriver à un moment où est ce
que chaque la pression est tellement
élevé que ce que sam stop ça fait pas ce
mot ce que sa fille s'y met on cache
sans que le il ya tellement la ferc
s'accumulent qui sont comme des charges
mental ouais on dirait que mon cerveau
est capable de décortiquer tout noir
puis de faire ça c'est la priorité
règle une fois qu'ils ont réglé ça tu
penseras l'autre priorité et puis tout
ça va s'accumuler vert comme tout clair
il
messieurs les jeunes ont effectivement
deux raisons je suis pas paralysé par ce
bruit parce que mettez mettons toi ce
matin tavin meeting important
cet après midi à faire était important
très stressant mois probablement que
dans les jours avant ou la journée même
tu étais venu ici avant de régler les
affaires pour ne travailler sur des
trucs qui t'était la france et après moi
je pense que j'aurais été paralysée
dorée quand celle des affaires by
georges arrêtez pas été capable de faire
autre chose parce que georges trop un
dossier à fond dans ma taille top-15
aussi la vente ou de la place prévoit de
faire autre chose
mais même pour tous pour dire que je
pense et ce qui qui détermine qui
différencie un peu sûrs qu'ils sont
faits pour pour l'entrepreneuriat je
sais pas si ma chance à prendre je pense
pas que c'est inique qui est une loterie
le pas dans son ensemble mais mewes et
souhaitait justement toi tu t'avances
puis à chaque jour ghachi tu donnes tu
avances puis cissé en ligne droite je
vais t'avouer même que maintenant j'ai 2
2 deux entreprises à ces différents
points puis qu'une entreprise ou est ce
qui te le contrôle absolu c'est vraiment
plus facile à gérer
c'est maintenant le studio là je dis pas
que j'ai le contrôle absolu je dois plus
techniquement on a chacun contrôle à 50%
diola lui même et en octobre c'est rare
qu'on est en désaccord sur ce jeudi
depuis qu'on est tout petit l'apport
pour des estime 15 avril
on a remué d'aidé xian mais c'étaient
des estime marc de l'outil tout ce qui a
un lien que le studio est capables de
rationaliser une information on est en
accord tout le temps le tchèque fait que
c'est facile sur c'est facile psylle
phone pour moi maintenant je le vois
comme un jeu de faire genre qui mène
comment qu'on fait pour atteindre le
prochain niveau
le comment qu'on fait + à toutes ces
affaires là c'est nous qui contrôlent
ces reconduites ont mal dans mon autre
business ou est-ce que les yeux plus
d'intervenants puis le cam est encore le
je pense que j'ose espérer que le ça va
aller pour le mieux parce que maintenant
mais comme c'est c'est de la gestion
même pis c'est ça qui gardent réveiller
le soir précédent
à voir l'espèce de boule dans le ventre
de gamme ce que j'étais en train de ne
pas faire la bonne affaire quand couche
le soir puis de lever un peu en panique
parce que tu es encore le feeling que tu
fais pas mon enfant artistes pour le
studio mais ne s'est pas arrivé ouais
ouais ça même si je veux dire je connais
rien l'entrepreneuriat même ça fait
quinze minutes que j'enfile mais
j'aurais jamais dit si tu m'aurais dit
yeves le deuxième même plein entre
m'arrêter un manoir de business dans six
mois je t'aurais du fioul
c'est sûr que non tu m'écoutes mais on
apprend chaque jour chaque jour mais
c'est ce jeu dépassé de l'athlète
artistes entrepreneurs est quand même
fort bien formé je sais pas l'atteinte
de buman servia c'est ça la force et
surtout l'absence de buman que ce soit
dans le sport dans l'entrepreneuriat
dans ce qu'il entreprend général c'est
comme tu veux t'en aller le puits
tu penses que vous voyez dès le début je
pense que l'objectif c'est le
dépassement personnel vraiment puis moi
ça a toujours été ça mentation t oui je
voulais atteindre un certain niveau je
voulais gagner des courses je voulais et
et dont j'avais des objectifs concrets
le mais ce qui était le plus gratifiant
puis c'est un cliché mais ce qui était
le plus gratifiant c'était de loin pas
un best-of de loin
il n'y a jamais rien qui a égalé sur sûr
que rien n'est jamais un canadien
universitaire stéphane c'était grotte
toi mais les gagnants à bestheim comme
accor provincial semaine c'était au
dessus de haute puis je pense que c'est
ça dans l'entrepreneuriat c'est vraiment
de dire ok mais ton oncle sans filtre ok
on a des stades sont les voies nos stats
skhirat men se dépasser nos stats c'est
pas de dire on est x grecque
comparativement y pique selon sans col
est sûre c'est quand même on fait quoi
de qualité on resserre rassembler du
monde ont réussi à s'améliorer on veut
s'adonner
meyer à devenir plus gros ça c'est au
tpi se situe la plaine dans toutes les
soirées ta vie c'est comme ça cestas
laisse justement c'est pas rien que des
stades s'est dit vraiment exception s'il
ya plus de monde qu'ils écoutent ça veut
dire que le plus de monde qui qui qui
qui sont influencés touché qui sont
qu'ils sont intéressés par ce qu'on a à
dire tirer fax et ce qui est gratifiant
c'est comme un gant on a quelque chose à
dire
j'imagine quelque chose d'intéressant à
partager qui nous écoutent l'iphone
exact maison maison puis on est dans
l'esprit du nouvel an pour rappel
l'année 2010 9 satine grosse année pour
le sans-fil podcast est une année de
croissance a été une année de plein de
monde qui ont commencé à nous écouter
parce qu'il ya plein de monde qui ont
commencé à parler à nous écrire à parler
du podcast sinon en haut du monde qui
ont commencé très tôt mais aussi ses
hôtes
si on ne consulte est quelque chose qui
aurait pu être un foot pas été une coupe
de podcasts il est à la mode et podcasts
mais là c'est comme qui n'ont ni loeb
puis on est là pour rester et puis les
gens vertébrale dans le paysage si on
voit pas le monde sont ceux on parla de
sécurité cette année nous autres pays
j'entrerai ce rendez-vous qui sommes des
gens qui nous écoutent
on vous remercie parce que c'est tout ça
n'existerait pas sans vous nous donc
c'est vraiment incroyable
mais messi si tu viens tu les geeks
avaient tant qu'amateur c'est en suisse
et sur serein vis pas de casque devait
s'y rendre l'âme à ce que vous faites
pire chose vous recevrez jamais mike
ward on le fait en 2019 faut pas votre
chaîne existe repris en 2000 il va
arriver ça c'est le pacage du 31
décembre sur les deux autres pas de
casse l'industrie qui vont sortir
confirmé mon âme qu'on est là mais non
non ouais on est encore là j'espère
qu'ils écoutent encore
qui dit qu'ils allaient mettre 100
piasses note péter j'attends j'attends
ton cash de pied ferme le paysage des
paysages podcast au québec changé même
drastiquement depuis qu'on a start et se
dit ça touche rock à travers toutes les
choix que les gens se voit ça se voit
offrir sans fil parce qu'à la base c'est
ce avant qu'on arrive il y avait déjà
plein au centre mais les plus populaires
c'est des podcasts souvent du mot
évidemment et d'autre des podcasts de
conversation et des invités variés tout
ce qu'on parle de tout de rien pendant
deux ans il y en avait mais y en avait
beaucoup moins c'est clair maintenant
que le chemin qu'ils ont choisi
d'écouter une autre plutôt qu'un autre
bain c'est doublement gratifiant tout à
fait c'est vraiment vote
on voulait mettre une coupe des extraits
non c'est pas dire c'est qu'on fait si
je te demandais à un moment marquant des
dépôts de cas ce qu'on a fait cette
année il ajouté mettant un ou deux
outils et maintenant c'est quoi ton
highlight le août et allied de ce qu'on
a fait jusqu'à une cette année mais ton
je m'étais fait une petite liste parce
que je savais qu'on avait abordé le
sujet avant mais maintenant que j'en
avais genre un ou deux anneaux mais je
dirais probablement lizana doute une
personne hors du commun
c'est pesé rona d'autres personnages
comme un bien venue deux fois ici c'est
des premiers parcs à ce qu'on a fait est
revenue deuxième fois puis à la quelque
chose de fil des différents et est
tellement fleur de peau tellement
intense comme en pro justement des
émotions tellement
et c'en est déconcertant puis on a vécu
une émotion laquelle le tlm en plus en
plus toi tu avais une rupture qui était
fraîche dans les mémoires très très
fraîche que j'en ai pas déçus podcast
d'ailleurs il ya du monde qui ont appris
du monde de ton entourage
non mais tout mon entourage mes sauts
d'ailleurs je veux m'excuser parce qu'il
ya des 6 am i am the ses connaissances à
elles qui ont écrit george what the fuck
genre qu'est ce qui se passe parce
qu'ils ont écouté le podcast filles ont
appris qu'ils ont dépuis ensemble là
dessus ce qui est un peu donne pour
qu'il ne faut pour le dire mais qu'est
ce que c'est l'avis des d'être des têtes
des qualités à faire un peu de chance il
exactement comme des choses qui vont
arriver mais mais c'est ce dont tu es
moi je t'ai commune à fleur de peau puis
elle ou citoyen il est dit des choses
qui l'ont touché à lui être la larme à
l'oeil jusque là mal et lui aussi
qu'ils soient ici ça a été un bon moment
fait que peut-être mettre à l'extrême
dans la caste on va faire une transition
vraiment blogueur plus comme éric
salvail d'ensemencer bon moment la
caméra sur michael extraits
[Musique]
dit à ce moment-là dans ta vie qu'est ce
que tu faisais pendant sks
qu'aujourd'hui tu sais ce que c est ce
que tu sais ce que c'est mais n'entendre
que tout je me suis préparé à ça j'ai
j'ai pensé beaucoup en sachant que ça
lui revient sur ce sujet puis je sais
pas prêtes on en parlait ce réseau je me
suis fait demander beaucoup puis pas
répondu parce que je sais pas quoi dire
j'ai pas de j'ai peur que on est en
couple exclu l'excusé est exclusif est
ce que c'est un concept qui toi te fait
peur une certaine façon ou douteux
craintive ainsi nous connaissent mais
toi même te connaissant pas moi de
connaissance oui mais toi tu connais
sans toi toi sachant que commenter
comment tu sais ça parce que ce que
j'avais peur pourquoi j'avais peur de le
dire c'est que j'avais peur que ça ça
enlève la valeur à ce que j'avais avec
jean-michel m
j'avais vraiment peur de le dire puis
parce que jean michel c'est normal je
m'excuse la tequila qui transparaît au
nom n'a de l'armagnac plus ici avec la
maman de prendre imposant propos n'est
pas surprenant plus
[Rires]
ce serait prendre les exprime c'est long
mais c'est tout à fait normal je
comprends ce que tu faisais pipi jamais
du moins nous on va penser que de
progresser dans dans ton raisonnement
dans la façon que tu vois la vie enlève
quoi que ce soit la façon de te vécu la
vie avance ça a rien à voir vraiment
c'est juste quelqu'un qui change pas son
attitude face à à la vie face aux
relations
c'est pas nécessairement positifs tout
le temps puis toutes les relations des
dynamiques sont différentes aussi c'est
qu'ils s'installent tranquillement tpiy
puis chacun puisse au pit il y en a qui
ont différentes modèles de coupe qui
sont heureux puis le dans nos moments de
leur vie avec une autre personne ce nom
de modèle pcc c'est correct et des
riches qui a une diversité là dedans
quand vers cette façon de vivre sa vie
pis si ce titre la nouvelle relation il
ya une dynamique s'est installée puis
vous en naissant de parler plus est tenu
que les deux de tes mieux l'installation
de type comme si chaque relation
vraiment différente pitt et chaque
relation compose de personnes fait que
le mix et un ajustement de deux
personnes c'est puis shon pour lui si
mettons y embrasser une autre fille pour
lui ça veut dire que ces émotions il ya
des émotions c'est lui est pas c'est
aussi dans ce sens que si mes temps jean
michel crochet quelqu'un puis je n'étais
même pas grave parce que c'était
tellement me dise pas grave genre on
s'aime enfin la journée tchèque en
votant par l'obr autour d'une guerre
c'est correct
cishan fait sur ça veut dire quitte en
amour avec quelqu'un d'autre qui s'étale
une autre intention fixée et puis lui la
façon qu'ils voient mettons la sexualité
où le couple c'est un autre mon pied je
dis pas que j'ai envie je me fais
comprendre clairement que ce n'est pas
un modèle qui aiment et non plus
mais je pense que par amour il vivait
pareil qui ta place de mettre pied ça
tant pis en même temps je pas en train
de dire que j'ai pas innocente là dedans
je m'en doutais que ce n'est pas l'idéal
pour lui je savais toi tu es dans dans
l'état d'esprit que tu étais à ce moment
là est-ce que notre homme si je dis que
si lui avait mis sa limite l'os arrêt
juste signifier la fin de la relation
travaille vraiment
[Musique]
on est de retour arrête sinon d'autres à
l'être moi je suis un grand fan des
admirateurs et je n'ai immense respecte
on a parlé après être passée avec adamo
pied 17 mais on ne peut vraiment étayer
ce sujet là monsieur ingrat qui rend fin
de deuxième machine à machine puis ben
dewar qui est un fan fest ces malades
bien lui puis india india desjardins
qu'on a reçues sur le podcast
micro-ondes jeunesse qui sont des fans
sans filtre ces malades mais ben oui
mais tu es mondial en toute ma formation
universitaire maîtrise en littérature
quand je connais sont quand même plus
qu'un bac avec un dec en arts et lettres
mais dont la maison desjardins c'est une
légende dans son domaine dans son
domaine en france et puis le gouverneur
aussi fait que qui écoute le sans fil
c'est malade mental ben oui c'est ce
qu'indiquent des gens qui respectent
autant te respecte également six
tellement ça fait tellement chaud au
coeur c'est incroyable mais justement
olivier py lui qui vient sur podcast
si on s'était parlé par email avant
qu'ils aient dit je n'ai pas vraiment
parler en entrevue jarret métier est ce
sujet-là des injections de vitamines si
que ça me tentait pas d'en parler mais
avec vous ce réaliste tu veux pas parler
et on en passe de parler mais pas mais
tu finiras par les que nous aurons des
parfums et à qui
puis a été folle ouvert ne faut leur
parler longtemps raconté cette histoire
le 2 sept
genre de polémique lors de
l'intimidation de kaki et puis
l'acharnement quelqu'un qui subit un de
ces lobbys le finalement le tpiy toute
la saga pythie finalement récemment reçu
un prix la côte est de desserrer tenu
debout mains pour pour la science
vraiment chapeau à lui mais c'est encore
doublement justement fun de savoir que
ces gars là il ne fait assez confiance
pour s'ouvrir à nous mais aussi je pense
exactement je sais pas si tu te
rappelles mais olivier la première fois
qu'ils venus chez nous ouais moi y'a 20
10 contre pessotto rogen qui était loin
d'être d'être impressionné par le cas
contraire surtout google lui à l'est
mais pas du tout
puis à se tasser à ma chute à l'est au
lancement du deuxième livre de recettes
de jean-philippe sourire qu'on a reçu
aussi sur le podcast
puis j ai croisé india desjardins qui
était le m audy je pense que tu racontes
des histoires mais maudit et en passant
olivier il me dit quelque chose puis il
vous leurrez pas 10 parce qu ils trop
introverti billets trop gêné pour vous
le dire mais dit je comprends ce que
vous trouvez à joburg
mais ce que joe hogan n'a pas que vous
avez c'est le sens critique
c'est l'esprit critique puis de se faire
dire ceux là nestea compliment venant de
libye berne à ses hôtes
c'est vraiment le fun mais c'est
l'histoire moi je pensais qu'il y avait
commencé flamme à l'écouté plus pia
après 69 ans non même bien avait dit
avait dit comprendre et de l'ouverture
d'esprit de john logan est ce que vous
avez que joe hogan n'a pas assez
l'esprit critique
c'est un beau compliment se pardonner
par l'ivi bernard on peut couper à un
extrait
[Musique]
tu es un exemple de sujet de cette année
au pays ben oui on a parlé tantôt de
l'épisode que j'ai fait sur
l'accouchement dans la saison 2 par
exemple cet épisode leleu me terrifiait
le il me terrifiait où l'épisode sur
l'allaitement que j'ai fait pour toi
pour une seule bonne raison ça concerne
des enfants puissent tchèque est très
émotif fait que souvent ben ça amène des
semaines suivant les arguments faisant
un homme qui est maintenant une grande
salle c'est tout seul effectivement mais
qu'est ce donc
donc c'est un bon exemple si je
m'attendais au pire ces deux épisodes
ont été reçus le magnifiquement puis
tant pis si je suis pas fier de tout ça
mais maintenant et j'ai fait un épisode
sur les suppléments de protéines chez
les sportifs puis je me suis auto menacé
de me faire causer de c'était surprenant
avec la fin de la vitamine c c'était un
de ces sujets là pour moi c'est un sujet
ben ordinaire ce qui arrive c'est
carrément donné pour ceux qui sont pas
au courant
il ya une pétition qui commence à
circuler pour faire supposément approuvé
les injections de vitamines c
pour les personnes qui ont le cancer
c'est pas pour traiter le cancer c'est
que je posais bien que ça diminue les
effets secondaires pour les gens qui
sont sur la chimio mais quelqu'un que de
la chimiothérapie pour leur cancer
existe que si son objectif de la
vitamine c est au moins d'effets
secondaires de la chimie au genre moins
de monde quand des choses comme ce bon
avec la pétition circule la pétition
comme beaucoup beaucoup en popularité
avec moi j'ai fait un article comme j'en
fais sur n'importe quel sujet day une
pétition qui circule voici ce que la
pétition demande
j'ai pris chacune des demandes une après
l'autre j'ai regardé sud reste à faire
le sou logique ça à toute censure qui
avait pas grand chose qu'ils avaient du
sens là dedans donc j'ai fait sur moi
d'une façon candide en m'attendais à ce
que ça soit tombé naïvement bah oui si
je me disais je me dis ça en fait je
pensais que les gens feraient comme à
nice coule
je les signe la pétition est maintenant
je sais plus à commander ou je me
demandais si je la signe tout de suite
je m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils sont mais
a pris d'où vient cette idée lors que la
vitamine c pure
est-ce que johnny étude à ce sujet leur
qui disait qu'il y avait des bénéfices
des injections et m6 qui est déjà us qui
ait quelque chose derrière ce qu'une
science est une super vieille de il je
pense que ça remonte aux années 50
un chimiste qui a gagné deux prix nobel
pour peut en faire un prix nobel de la
paix parce que il y avait des trucs
qu'on pense les nazis ou juste pas trop
quoi lâche pas trop sur ce niveau là qui
a aussi fait un
il ya aussi gagné un prix de la paix à
un prix nobel en chimie pour une
découverte au niveau des liaisons
chimiques
un scientifique incroyable qui aident à
la fin de sa carrière il ya panier n'est
celle de bouille a commencé à penser que
la vitamine c ça fait tout de guérir
tout qu'existe le cancer de la bloque
tout seul puis encore aujourd'hui les
gens continuent à croire que lui ce
qu'ils pensaient à l'époque ça a été
prouvé ou démontrer tout seul en réalité
à toutes les fois que ça a été testé ces
hypothèses ça marcherait jamais et là
dans les dernières années il ya eu un
regain d'intérêt un peu pour cette
saisie des loques la vitamine c peut
faire plein de la plein de choses mais
la réalité c'est que des études qui
disent que ça guérit x y z jeu à la
chouchoute ses galeries ses discours
bulot c'est une carence en vitamine c il
prend le manque de prendre les
injections de vitamines 10 soit votre
guérir il est vrai bien ça va c'est
assez facile elle cherche une de nos
jours hu est assez facile à aller
chercher mais dans le cas du cancer
c'est particulier parce que tu linge qui
est revenue à être venus des cas pas
d'aller chercher des concentrations bout
qu'on va vraiment plus élevé que ce que
tu pourrais aller chercher avec des
comprimés par la butch donc c'est là que
commence à dire ok mais tu vas chercher
des concentrations aussi élevé ce que ça
peut pas avoir un effet justement au
niveau sanguin au niveau justement des
des effets secondaires de toutes les
mécanismes qui se passe avec la
chimiothérapie le sait cela sur leurs
prétentions puis quand tu arrives avec
ok voici mais voici où on en est
scientifiquement voici les résultats des
études sur le sujet y a pas vraiment
création en des injections du domaine
c'est qui
des bénéfices td propos il ya pas de
preuve preuve que ça marche et amène
certaines preuves que ça peut ne pas
marcher et probablement être dangereux
ok donc quand tu arrives avec ce comment
c'est reçu que c'est quoi la réaction
parce que clairement la verge la
réaction cessé de nier ou 6 2 et dans d
accord avec toi mais c'est quoi la
comment ça se manifeste si kohler si
j'ai eu vraiment un bon mélange
la plupart des gens qui ont réagit mon
antique était super contente comme
marcoule c'est intéressant je l'avais vu
cette pétition le chapeau trop quoi en
penser les gens qui supportait la
pétition qui ou kick était très très
investi là-dedans parce qu'il avait
signé qui croyaient vraiment la patente
c'est sûr qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
était pas content puis tout ça mais là
ce qui s'est passé c'est que moins ce
sujet là je ne sais pas pourquoi mais ce
sujet il m'a interpellé plus que
d'autres c'est comme si j'ai fait je
sais pas il ya quelque chose d'un sujet
là que je me suis dit que quelque chose
là j'ai senti que je senti que tu es un
con que c'est un conte un peu charnière
ben j'ai vu comment ça s'enligne d'un
coup j'ai vu au pilote d'un coup il ya
un politicien il ya lieu où il est
pilote est en train de dire que lille va
prendre cette pétition le qui vont
l'amener à l'assemblée nationale soit la
défense va faire des pressions le
j'entendais des affaires entre les
branches qui avaient des profils la
santé qui avait que s'était senti obligé
peut-être de donner de la vitamine c
le taux de 100 de gap qui avait plus que
je suis la question le voilà qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui sous-entendait
qui était sous jacente où j'ai senti
n'était pas juste une compétition reine
qui avait vraiment un mouvement dans
d'autres ce qu'ils voulaient vraiment
faire quelque chose puisque j'ai
l'impression que ça paraissait un peu
sous le radar puis que le tout d'un coup
tout s'est accéléré peut demander même
le politicien en question il ya même dit
on veut savoir commission parlementaire
avec s'appuie tout ce qu'on en attend
plus on va vraiment investir des fonds
publics là dedans pour une commission
parlementaire pour parler de quelque
chose
ultimement que ça devrait être juste une
question de qu'est ce qu'on sait au
niveau des données scientifiques sadr
est juste sur la question pensent pas
aux adresses terminé le bas c'est à dire
que un médecin le
si vos parents sont pas mais vous savez
comment ça marche un médecin ça prescrit
un a prescrit un médicament s'ils jugent
que le médicament est efficace que
sécuritaire s'y oppose ses preuves le
même problème qui vaut pas le prescrire
tiens parce que c'est juste nous a
beaucoup apprécié ce n'est pas éthique
dans le vent est en train fait que
pourquoi est ce qu'on demande
d'autoriser des injections
pourquoi ne te retourne pas autorisée
rien d'illégal
si les médecins prescrivent pas c'est
parce que on n'a pas de preuves qu'un
médecin faire quelque chose
pourquoi t'es pourquoi passer par un
politicien qui est pas un expert en la
matière qui connaît pas pour que lui
mettre la pression sur des médecins ou
c'est leur domaine de savoir sur sa
aucun sens pour moi c est coutume est
vraiment le doigt sur la patente
moi j'ai senti qu'ils avaient de
l'ingérence il y avait de l'ingérence
politique dans un sujet qui est purement
scientifique c'est là que ça m'agace
c'est que j'ai si j'ai fait beaucoup des
mises à jour sur cet article pendant un
an à peu près puis plus en plus ça
allait pire c'est à dire qu'il y avait
un groupe de personnes qui étaient
probablement des signes envers la
pétition j'imagine mais que
progressivement le jeu voyait des
messages passaient ils sur les réseaux
sociaux que le gt2 venu comme l'ennemi à
abattre
c'est comme un banc de neige était sur
mon facebook que je voyais saviez vous
que le faire marcher ce point vrai
pharmaciens en personne vient de
découvrir ce jeu devrait pharmacie
commencé à avoir des défauts aux
informations qui circulaient sur -1
manie avait déjà une autre fakes news du
phare machines telles affalé m'accusait
de fake news ou le shaker matin c'est
comme trame fait aux états unis qui
accusent les immédiate fakes news ici
après ça il y avait quoi y avait aussi à
huy avait aussi des gens qui parlaient
des citations disait voici ce que le
pharmacien dit aujourd'hui blabla comme
jamais dit si comme tout jeu pauvres
ceux qui ont pris cette citation au
lausanne station complètement inventés
ou oust et deux bouts de phrases qui
avait pris dans deux commentaires les
avait mis aux enchères de los teques
panade et moi ayons comme c'est comme si
on monte un faux personnage de son fils
se sont comme monter un personnage que
je suis pas c'est dans le sens dans ce
que je fais des fois je t'aurais pu
jeter un peu baveux et puis tout cela
mais pendant ce que si je trouve pas que
je l'avais été vraiment je trouve
j'avais été quand même propres mais y
ont vraiment créé le personnage qui est
un monstre essentiellement et là c'est
sûr qu'en faisant ça ils ont monté leurs
troupes y ont craqué leurs toits qui ont
indiqué à leurs machines séquelles
un vrai pharmaciens garder les affaires
qui a dit qu'ils n'ont pas de bon sens
il fait défection me fais ci fais ça et
le tout d'un coup il ya un paquet de man
qui ont fait ok titre golog on le
conçoit
c'est assez le jeu est un monstre il
faut les longues et qui ont créé la wii
mais oui c'est ça c'est le personnage
images qui ont agressé un [ __ ]
selon toi le quotidien est-ce que tu
penses que c'est un groupe organisé
fonctionne a aussi dit c'est une gang de
loup solitaire mais qui agissent de la
même façon en même temps je pense que
c'est pas un groupe organisé mais je
pense que c'est des gens qui se sont
parlés sur les réseaux sociaux et qui
ont décidé un moment donné de façon
informelle de comme faire une sorte d'
action ti en disant par exemple man et
puis le sait ce qui est arrivé
ça a été des mois et des mois vraiment
là que c'était un niveau de aïn et
d'insultés qui étaient quotidiens le
vraiment le camp j'ai jamais vécue que
tu recevais un message privé un message
public les de la retourne les deux pipes
honnêtement ça ne dérange pas jean ça me
dérange vraiment propice aux tout petits
quelqu'un qui est quand même une bonne
carapace à ce niveau d'autant que
honnêtement mais je dois le fait que tu
fais ce que tu fais y en a pas beaucoup
qui ferait ce que tu fais à l'abandon
mais je comprends ce que tu veux dire
en fait je pense que la façon je le vois
plutôt si il ya un travail qui doit être
fait puis moi c'est comme si je les
accepte je les assume que j'essaie de
voir la façon c'est moi qui décide de
faire le pharmacien c'est moi qui décide
et parler du sujet qui sont sensibles au
fait comment n'ai je peux pas me
plaindre après que ça crée de la que ça
crée de la simili controverse jeudi à
maurice comme j'ai un écart était de
faire ça si ça ne plaît pas je l'accepté
le won his a comme fuck et si on veut
c'est que m emmenez moi je sentais que
c'était en train vraiment d'accès les
risques patente le à un niveau vraiment
km en juin
et là le fameux pot lithium en est en
fait un point sur sa page facebook où il
dit ok on s'en va en commission
parlementaire avec ça c'est la troisième
pétition la plus populaire de tous les
temps et la commission parlementaire
vont nous permettre d'en savoir plus
finalement sur les injections de
vitamines c est le moins j'ai fait tout
bonnement j'ai fait et je voyais crise
reste goal of et j écris sur son pouce
carré mais je suis fait chaud c'est un
commentaire sur son opposant 10e
monsieur x les politiciens j'ai dit je
lis votre affaire le pouvez vous
expliquer juste questions simples
peuvent expliquer en quoi une commission
parlementaire vont nous en apprendre
plus sur le sujet en france
essentiellement sur des questions
scientifiques cela ce stade ci fait que
pourriez-vous juste nous éclairer sur la
question en gros c'est ce que j'ai dit
et là ça a passé
l'avalanche et la cellule qu'ils ont
fait oki stade wallon le sud est et le
ski ont fait essentiellement c'est
qu'ils se sont comme consolidé pour dire
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour le
cancer dont qui ont fait des appels à
tous en disant ok tout le monde on porte
plainte massivement radio can parce que
radio can simon diffusant le radio can
d'un coup obs
ils ont dit qu'ils ont écrits en
écrasant la radio kahn à qui d'autre on
peut écrire à il ya le fond telus qui
finance sa série télé à toronto on va
leur écrire massivement fonds telus pour
qu'ils quittent des finances sa série à
qui donc on peut écrire on va cuire à
l'ordre des pharmaciens portons plainte
massivement à l'ordre des pharmaciens à
ok après ça aion blanc nuit sa blonde
senza desjardins à l'écrit des romains
ont pas écouté ses livres ont fait un
appel au boycott de ces livres si on dit
que les livres de ma blonde des torchons
et qu'il fallait les boycotter ma blonde
à l'heure aucun rapport avec ce que je
souhaitais
ils ont révélé l'adresse d'une pharmacie
où je travaille l'ama faire la femme la
pharmacie principale je travaille et il
y avait aussi des menaces de mort ont
traversé la limite européenne est là
honnêtement moi j'ai fait ok ça rime
mais là c'est plus quelque chose que je
suis prêt à accepter un jeune en prendre
des insultes pendant huit mois là mais
quand je vois pas accepter ce pour moi
le ce a franchi une limite que ça
devient dangereux carrément watson ça
atteint un niveau où on peut pas et on
off
il ne faut pas qu'on accepte soit c'est
là que j'ai fait mon j'ai fait un statut
sur ma page prend à les pilot bike
mais dieu merci tout va ses études quand
même parce qu'il ya eu un espèce de
changement paradis quoi exactement en
fait ce qui est arrivé là c'est que moi
je parle a dit moi je disais et ça
serait le fun qui a aidé associations
médicales scientifiques qui qui viennent
ans qui parle qui prennent position sur
le sujet qu'ils ont colloque qui parlent
tout ça parce que mouche pour une
expérience de tout événement si les gens
peuvent toujours the wall pharmaciens
connais pas ce que c'est mais les gens
qui sont dans les potions d'autres
scientifiques il
vrai peut-être en parler puis prendre le
relais c'est moi c'est ce que je
demandais mais je pense que c'est un
sujet qui était perçu comme sensibles
personne voulait vraiment se mouiller
qu'un convoi qu'est ce qui t'arrive à
toi et ne va pas avoir beaucoup de monde
qui voulait se prêter au jeu
à ce stade là il savait pas c'est répond
que non ils savaient pas encore si il
savait pas ce que je vivais ça se
faisait un peu en dessous lice en
coulisses et le quand j'ai fait ma
sortie en express qui se passait le je
pense que c'est surtout quand tu parles
du changement de paradigme c'est clair
il ya un pas que nous ayons fait ok ça
se passe au québec c'est à ferland ce
moment nos jeunes on le savait qu aux
états-unis en arrive des affaires comme
ça le cuir du harcèlement qu'on fait
perdre les jobs à des scientifiques sur
des enfants pas de bon sens 'pitot' mail
il ya un paquet de jeunes en communauté
scientifique à temps mais ça n'a pas de
bon sens je sais ça on peut pas laisser
faire ça et l'autre de cuyo paquet monti
ont sorti en disant ok mais le goal on
va on va se prononcer publiquement fait
qu à la limite le plus grand succès de
cette affaire là ça a été ça a été que
tu ne me sortir des gens des six a amené
un peu de warner city ça fait que des
gens qui étaient peut être un beauf
n'est pas au courant que tout ça se
tramait
lochte au courant hockey le il faut
qu'on se prononce
[Musique]
moi si nos podcasts puis j'en parlais
avec nicole je savais qu'on embarque un
i pod casse highlights ipod cas je pense
depuis les tout débuts
c'est boucar diouf le monde me disait
toujours bout car il faut savoir c'est
que après avoir fait un paquet avec
boucar diouf on a tellement tous les
deux équipés que pendant à peu près une
semaine on faisait juste se parler de ce
puits chaque chose qu'on disait on le
disait en commençant avec cette phrase
de mon grand père disait toujours au
bout car peu importe qu est-ce qu on
disait non métier moi c'est le podcast
probablement que je me suis fait le plus
parler
ouais par tout le monde par des gens de
mon entourage des amis des bons amis à
qui j'ai danger à l'université qui
écoutait pas de podcasts avant celui-là
sont tombés sur boukari qui ont réécouté
depuis le début tous les podcasts qui
arrêtait pas de me dire que c'est de la
bombe que du monde que je connais c'est
pas que je montre qu'il partageait sur
facebook sur internet d'eramet
ça a été un gros podcast oui on l'a reçu
ouais puis tous les autres pas de casse
n'ont reçu après oui parce que ça
m'évite et sa naïveté merveilleux
merveilleux un autre niveau des jsf
illustre le premier qui faisaient ne le
dit il ressortit se soucier une autre
affaire qu un des meilleurs moments de
ma vie
c'est afin de podcasts qui nous
regardent et qui dit ouais j'ai jamais
parlé autant biologie ont ils parlent de
la palourde royale on y demande de
parler des stores son grand-père crise
le gain est en fait il était professeur
en bio à l'université puis par jamais de
bio fields c'est ce dont on est dans
d'avec le fait d'un micro piteux peut
parler de bio ça va être passionnant
pendant deux ans puis ont été passionnés
ont été pendus à ses lèvres des bus afin
de seppi c'est un gosse immensément et
d'exemples historiques qui quittait
qu'il fonde pas ce qui est complet aussi
parce qu'ils aient
il mélange la science scientifiques mais
aussi la poésie pineau most of fact
comme toutes ces transferts l'heure
c'est beau c'est dit c'est vrai c'est
drôle quand diouf j'ai pas un extrait en
particulier il ya après que pâques à sa
sortie si on est mou dire écoute pas
tous le défaut d débute dès fois
annoncée puis le dévoile podcast fini
pis ce comme floue le t on le dit plein
d'affaires mais le seul m'a manqué c'est
qu'on a dit qu'on en a parlé c'est comme
c'est comme un espèce de flou c'est
qu'il ya un monde qui m'écrivait des
amis à moi qui vais crime est un message
privé mais qui vaisseau de mise à terre
en lettres majuscules
c'est pourquoi tout le monde décrit ce
dernier d'accord puisse pas ce qui avait
coûté bout car piqué à manipal d'etienne
race d'extraterrestres des mises à terre
qui arrivent ici puis sa signature ce
serait pas beaucoup même parler des
extraterrestres les médiateurs je pense
que oui winkel tension mais c'est drôle
ça fait deux fois qu'on parle de votre
atterrissage à tort dans le studio sfr
victoire adam oman le papier ce qui est
fait avec rick pagano a amené l'ams
hydrique pagano et se mettre à triper
man legends est maintenant chez paul
s'il faudrait scary vicissitudes et se
donne et ne sais pas pourquoi les gens
une pas ça arrive ici pour nous acculer
qu'est ce qu'on va faire si lyon des
armes aux arts pour détruire la planète
c'est déjà aussi bien pour nous acculer
le csap la plus grande part j'adore
palais en huile j'en fais de la société
l'asadho excité extraits
[Rires]
[Musique]
si la terre était peuplée d'orchidées ce
serait catastrophique pour les insectes
pollinisateurs parce que l'heure qu'il
est il mystifie l'insecte pollinisateur
duty table tu vois les ya des orchidées
qu'on appelle les orchidées abel lafleur
ressemble tellement à la femelle d'une
abeille que calme à la rive et à
l'impression que c'est une femelle
donc il va pour s'accoupler n'est ce pas
et il donne son pollen pitt y va tous
vous voir féconder locales à un autre
mais ne peut rien y en a assez des
arrivées nocibé avoir imaginé toutes ces
concepts la chaîne cbs que c'est celle
de viande de lady gaga
ouais ouais j'ai invité un carnivore
pour l'attraper film anges et c'est
exact exact c'est celles de la marque
via wi
mais c'est mais c'est ça la beauté de la
nature je pense qu'il faut amener aux
jeunes en leur disant regarde regarde
comment des millions d'années comme tu
disais la dc d'erreur de fignolage ont
amené sa salle à tu peux aucune personne
ne sait le temps les orchidées a régné
aux autres leur co évolution c'est que
et vivent dans des environnements oui
des guêpes qui capturent des araignées
c'est les guêpes des fois capture des
araignées les guêpes solitaire les
paralyse les mettre dans le nid qui a
répondu en disant aux enfants dans le
frigo est plein là quand vous viendrez
au monde pouvait manger ça mais ils font
juste les paralyser la pour qu'ils
restent vivants mais assez horrible mais
c'est ça et donc les orchidées ce qu'ils
ont fait les orchidées à renier ceux qui
ont pris la fleur et de sam à une
araignée que la gap solitaire cherche
donc car la gappe solitaire est en
chasse voir la fleur puis parce que
c'est une araignée piles et c'est de
l'attrapé et puis je fais féconder comme
ça et en rdc stratégie comme ça et en a
en quantité industrielle
et c'est tout ça là comment quand tu le
regardes tu n'as pas le choix comme
individu quand tu t'intéresses on passa
de dire on peut pas ça quand j ça c'est
trop beau pia n'a pas d'autres planètes
y'en a pas ces recherches mais anna
paule aujourd'hui quelque chose qui me
kyi qui a résonné dans - piste est sur
la question de la vie extraterrestre
oui puis moi dans ma tête est en et
l'infinité pratiquement deux
possibilités de planèze louiset les
chances sont bonnes qui avait de la vie
ailleurs c'est sûr qu'après ça tout
amener une distinction tu te dis pour
kia et l'humain sa planète terre c'est
une suite de hasards infinie mais oui de
azor complet oui puis d'évolution des
petites afin 0,000001 % de chances qu'on
y retrouve ici maintenant
oui je me dis effectivement peut-être
que ya plus cette affaire-là york mais a
évolué différemment
oui oui je pense pas que la vie erreurs
mais je pense que la vie intelligente
technologique qui nous permet d'aller
dans l'espace puisque les héros je pense
que c'est extrêmement extrêmement rare
sinon il y en avait partout en tout cas
peut-être cana parce que l'univers
énorme mois c'est énorme et je n'aime
pas le terme mais moi je crois que on a
une belle planète
c'est là la 11è qu'elle existe elle est
là la vie quand on regarde on a calculé
si on ramenait l'histoire de la terre en
une journée de 24 heures
l'humain est apparu sur la terre à 23
heures 59 minutes et 56 secondes au sol
et là nous avons un rap seconde
existence
l'immersion mais si on prend l'histoire
de l'univers en termes assez l'histoire
de l'univers c'est encore pour beaucoup
aussi
ouais mais quatre saisons d'existence la
bien comme ça quand tu réussis à
bousiller parce que otis là on en a pas
vu de planeur avec de l'eau liquide
c'est l'eau liquide qui fait qu'on est
là c'est celle autorise une loterie
cosmique hubert reeves 10 à 12 soit
c'est une auto rico smic qui nous a
créés j'ai vraiment kiffé on est tombé
entre dans un étroit couloir du système
solaire compatibles
112 loi l'état liquide si on était un
peu plus loin ça gèle plus proche à ce
rapport et on est tombé au bon endroit
et pour moi en tout cas comme biologiste
qui adore les sciences de la vie je me
dis c'est la probabilité là c'est pas
ses 1,3 hors terre là ouais y'a pas de
piscine dans plus de liquide on n'a pas
vu un élément si j'étais sur une planète
ailleurs et que je je me développe la
commune autre forme d'intelligence et
que j'apprends qu'un homo sapiens m'a
découvert si je vais aller me cacher
ouais c'est sûr je sortirai plus jamais
parce que tu vois pas la voir c'est toi
qui va [ __ ] le bordel
l'histoire a prouvé par tout ce qui est
arrivé il ya détruit fait qu'à veut pas
être l'espèce envahi par l homo sapiens
quelqu'un qui avez dit lourd on avoue
qu'on voit c'est marc cela ne soyez pas
certains je suis sûr c'est les martiens
qui pleure en navarre nord quel humain
existe la cci stressant c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a pas les intérêts à 100 d'une
invasion extraterrestre parce qu'on se
projette à orthez oui si on se dit lui
même qu'il arrive en l'amérique ce oui
il ya conquis et détruit détruit mais
sont peut-être pas pacifique d'enfants
aux autres c'est juste que nous le
caractère on le projette sur les autres
intérêts ce qu'on pense trouver ça oui
et nous quand on les regarde c'est juste
pour chercher à une civilisation
exploiter et puis on souhaite mais à un
moment donné ils vont arriver ici ça va
être des sodomies thater
[Rires]
évoluer sur une planète qui sont allés
bonjour toi aimerait bien toi on me dit
est récent mais bon
[Musique]
el web un mois un podcast que je suis
particulièrement fier puis c'est aussi
lié à comment j'ai apprécié cette
personne là mais c'est le podcast qu'on
a fait avec yannick de martino parce que
yannick de martino chaque fois qu'on
l'entend c'est pour rire c'est pour être
drôle c'est pour est absurde
picque caillou venu ici premièrement on
avait un flop avec l'ordinateur avec on
a commencé une heure en retard il y
aurait pu être pistée répète made on a
jusqu à parler un peu en attendant puis
comme c'était c'était faux nil puis
finalement on s'est assis avec yannick
puis on a juste parlé de sa vie comme
comment il était maintenant de
psychologie de commun consulter pour son
anxiété
le kit pis encore une fois comme un peu
booker qui disait qui a jamais parlé de
bio il ya des cafés du podcast est dit
mais finalement on aura pas parler du
mot ouais c'est vrai mais c'est parfait
mais c'est parfait c'est parfait moi je
me rappelle le moment qui même qui m'a
marqué racontait qu'en qui était allée
puis évidemment si avec de martino fait
toutes ces anecdotes moins drôle si je
sais pas ce que c'est lui qui a raconté
mais il racontait qu'en qu'était qu'un
qu'avais je pense démissionner de sa job
- piqué après six revers croisé son
ancien patron puis qui avait comme
compris qu'elle ait fait quelque chose
de sa vie c'est après avoir dit qu'elle
accueille un phare de sa vie puis j'en
ai conseillé chez qui il veut pas se
victimiser jamais plaint de ne pas avoir
l'air d'avoir de faire pitié mais mais
ni le plus facile dans sa vie puis il ya
passé par des crises de oye-plage le
choc on connaît même pas qu'on ne m'aime
pas aucune idée là parce qu'ils en
parlent pas beaucoup sauf qui s'égrènent
ou vendre un peu sur ce puis deux puis
ça c'était vraiment un moment cool aux
podcasts et moi tu vois
depuis ce podcast le passage qui m'a le
plus marqué c'était le passage du savs
way we t-il été inversés en europe il
lui a lâché lapcipp l'abc fait
justement des salles yannick ça va ouais
ouais ouais ça vaut ça vaut à nant mince
m'appeler ah ben ça vaut oui ça à savon
et pourquoi tu pleures sûr ça va oui le
savons oui ça va c'est jenny puis petite
voiture jeudi la semaine passée avec
adamo puis j'ai c'est que les choses
dans le podcast et qu'on l'a on artistes
des expériences humaines qui nous change
le qui je demande plus jamais d'accord
ça va vite dans même des salles us a
voté au lac et anik parle plus ouais
c'est ça mais tdc ça ça m'arrive de
regarder dans les yeux de cacao puis
demande ils savent aussi un vrai ça
votre puits oui ceci c'est grâce à
yannick adresse aveu je pense qu'on va
les écouter l'extrait du savoir mais oui
exprès
[Musique]
il ya vraiment une estive différence en
ça soit aujourd'hui dans un podcast pij
a croisé quelqu'un oui mais oui dans sa
cassette puis faire la conversation mais
le jeu capable de mettre je cache un
petit peu plus le mot puis le je me
comprends mieux moi même que je sais le
dans dans ce type de rencontre le il
faut jouer au jeu il n'y a ni requis
qu'il n'y ait un peu faux projets
sélectifs en composent une question de
pi ca des projets déjà s'est vu que mon
je m'amuserais pas bien il faut gens
amènent sur une job a envoyé comme une
pièce des représailles et le phone régie
raisin m'emmener que ce qu'est ce qui me
rend mal à l'aise cette fois ça me tente
pas de salsa
oui il faut que je développe un peu mais
ça me tente pas jailli sur la deux pays
pas mal de projets ou télécoms allez
salut ça vote c'est juste le salue sa
volée puis le hockey jusqu'où est ce que
je suis prêt à répondre à cette question
le est-ce que j'ai commencé à faire ça
va ça va moyen le sait aujourd'hui
c'était plutôt fait avec ma blonde puis
je suis pas trop qu'est ce qu'on va
faire et comment tu fais ouais mais moi
il faut c'est le mot qu est ce qui me
fait mal d'efforts c'est de renvoyer la
question là bas comme bateau ça vole
c'est pas quelqu'un quand on prend une
petite discussion mais justement c'est
vraiment vraiment dans le sens léger
prône yagg
mais lol savons comment faire ouais
ouais ça vous parce que justement je
veux le faire de façon ça va tourner il
a même fait mal et tout et tout mais que
si j paul goulet ça vaut bien c'est sur
le travail pas mal fatigué je le mans
caen
[Rires]
dernière va je viens de déménager dans
une rue qui on donne on doit avoir 30 en
dessous de la moyenne d'âge la rue guy
mocquet fake c'est tout des voisins qui
on est comme le nouveau jeune couple
dans la rue puis j'ai jamais autant des
conversations de surface que ceux de
chez nous à mon sort comment chaque jour
une nouvelle personne qui s'occupait des
petits la catr chez monsieur x je vais
l'appeler monsieur m'approprier aussi à
14 chez monsieur x
ouais ok des jeunes ouais ouais ouais
mais presque 30 un système auto ce
qu'est c'est comme ça tous les jours
c'est ce qu'il dit déménager dans un
foyer parisien qui vient me torcher c1
mais kaka c'est ça pour ça on ait james
a quand même une chaussure réconfortante
parce que j'avais un pied à terre à
green bay que mon fils il y avait avec
sa mère à granby et mes voisins j'ai
trouvé mais y était pas non c'est pas
vrai y était pas sauf ajustements
c'était comme on le savait que la
relation était on se trouve on est des
voisins bon matin mais tu le vois qu'ils
ont comme pleut ça à offrir justement
puisque c'est un tellement senti un vrai
beau bon matin aïe ça vaut ça fait du
bien quand ça brille vraiment parce que
c'est vrai ça va c'est pas juste parce
qu'on respecte les conventions sociales
ça me fait plaisir ça et puis comme tout
le monde je vais pas tout à partir sur
parler du cosmos ces cartes mais aussi
dans sa vie
c'est donc à korma en place notre place
dans l'univers c'est sûr de bien aller
les grecs havrais ça vaut tous les sens
un vrai ça vaut le lit ainsi le droit
des yeux piqués genre ça m'intéresse
comment tu voles aux îles le justement
la casse et du oui toi prends le peuple
c'est comme ces japon pourrait être à ce
moment on parlait de même ce cas là mais
c'était c'était seulement début de les
ramener
ça va piloter oui mais toi tu la fais à
faire c'est sûr ça vous ça va l'être et
je vais essayer d'avoir brisé ma mère
c'était ma première séance est qu elle
toute seule de savon oui comme en
silence des vraiment 30 secondes qui a
wish mobileye je prends deux gorgées
d'eau vie c'est bon ils savent vraiment
mener jerry mais pourquoi sourit annick
parce que sa vente des vilains jerry
puma mais christophe pas que ça vaut oui
ok c'est off mais c'est le jeu c'est en
même temps un bonnet forte à tabriz et
monde
mais pourquoi tu pleures la has moi même
domaine j'ai fait je sais plus via ce
que j'ai fait c'est tellement puissants
les riches ça vaut bien placé sur le
bouton c'est fou avec avec leurs bonnes
intentions
on est tellement partout se faire
demander sincèrement le savons que ce
chaque fois je me faisais le supplice de
la goutte d'or l'achat comme à bonne
place est ce qu on est tellement habitué
que ça soit pas en bonne place a fait
savoir
oui mais là on savoure mais avec
quelques retards garde d'un soutien
gorge
bravo tu peux pas ya passé yens le type
même si ces oiseaux
non mais ça vous savez ça mais surtout
que tu allais aurait pu elle elle aurait
pu rester quatre menus alléchants
[Musique]
anyway yannick excellent choix mais
c'est excellent excellent choix
- pas de casque m'a marqué c'est le
pataquès deux jours doit ce golem haine
qui je veux parler du roi mais besoin du
roi je veux absolument qu'ils soient
plus présents mais ce golden age talent
à son show kesha son choix qu ariane 1
pis le gars y est extrêmement talentueux
genre ça peut pas être en deux sets et
et à quel point c'est un bon chanteur
ouais comme c'est pas un fournil est pas
là parce que son pari était riche le
comme c1 est bonne artistique
plus on est haut au shopi c'est moi je
triple moi je me dis dans ma taille ce
gala demain matin et wide wild
mais ces foules ces jarres jason mraz
et dax hitlantis assez débile le syli
n'est pas que nos puits afin de chaud il
est là il prend des photos avec ses
amitiés avec le monde sont venus le voir
ses fans qui est trop relax je viens de
voir que je fais m
c'était vraiment primeur garde qu'un
cutter garde du cycle de regarde trop
vieux ils parlent à toi pour vrai le
préfet cinq semaines mais s'ils
atteignent semaine plus ce mot tu vois
le plus relax le plus anti faisait plus
en israël puis himdi amène enfin
naveteur parler chez nous genre tu
ouvres ta blonde venue c'est quand on se
pointe le tout le monde parking semi
gens je passe un barman de monde et
relax puis le guen vient faire un show
qui a fucking n était tout le monde et
ce mode sable on est vraiment ce mappy
est quand même en chine zone euro dès le
show là ont peut-être le faire à 4,5
place mais je pense pas au mexique avec
ma blonde pour une retraite de hyundai
comme dit ma femme je prends pour mixer
avec ma femme pour une autre de lépine
mais motus et commandes comme en chine
et c'est pas la chose que je fais le
plus naturellement comme être relax
l'assemblée c'est comme porter par le
moment juste en étant avec lui même le
temps s'est arrêté pendant ce podcast le
toit et quand il était 1h30 1h40 ne suis
pas combien de temps sa durée mais
comment est-ce que tout le monde est
relax c'est goliath transpire le bien
être même si je vois que c'est ça
justement tissa kites accueille ainsi en
principe à apprécier la musique où
toutes les hautes sphères de sa vie vont
être comme collatéral à son bien-être
c'est quand même probablement que
tellement mangé de la marde dans sa vie
que l'oeil et ailleurs il dit ça en
était sûrs tels alain snipe bobby nadeau
politique même quand je parle de cette
affaire là on dirait que je parle pas du
même dieu
non c'est le gars qui a frappé kit qui
est allé tu vois pas 3 qui couche 2
remporte qui fait signature de traverser
à glace pour les tabasser l'autre ja on
dirait que je pars pas surpris mon truc
je parle même pas du même groupe i toute
cette histoire de grandir dans le
chalaux de pas 3 du tango leur mettre
des tangos leur dans leur clip ton père
ces patriotes aucune chance d'en sortir
puis le coeur il ya tellement du mange
de la marde je l'entendais le week-end
radio là où ken radio quitte une radio à
québec 91,9 week-end radio puis il
disait le gars weekend end tout comme tu
dois aimer sans recevoir les
commentaires qu'ils ont soit après des
performances comme ça puis a juste fait
ce disque web
j'ai arrêté de lire les commentaires
parce que j'ai tellement reçu de la
marde
quand j'étais plus jeune que j'ai arrêté
de regarder fait le deuil et un plr /
pitié on n'est pas là ça peut-être on
sait pas comment ça qu'elle vécut son
actif l'imaginé qui me tombe pendant là
pendant la première moitié de sa vie
genre notre petit jusqu'à 20 ans jusqu'à
19 21 il était clairement défini
justement par son passé pas tous y aller
c'était le fait ça sont pas faits c'est
le même job qui sont pas comme tu disais
jusqu'au moment ils disent oui disent
que je veux me définir moi même et y
voit justement quelle gueule il ya
vraiment entamer une qu'est une carte de
recherche de soi le des connaissance de
soi sa part et pis je suis sur des
constructions des côtes des
constructions de préavis de quesques et
s poser exactement exactement puis celui
ci l île il a exporté plus loin que
juste sa carrière puis disposera est
patrick roy et enfin non je peux se pose
est ce que je posais déjà l'entente voix
après ce qu'est ce que je suppose à dos
si je pose est un couple un couple
traditionnellement nos facs date ça
c'est pas c'est parce qu'ils me disent
qu'ils me plaît à moi d'être
hétérosexuel non mais non c'est pas ça
posted by ce mode est un chanteur qui
bosnie que les gros les bords évidemment
gros les baumes moi j'aime mieux femmes
et à faire de façon indépendante
quand je veux comme je le veux c'est le
guide et en plus il prend le contrôle de
service définies par les définit
lui-même il vit pas selon les normes il
vit selon qui ce qui vient de lui très
loin vraiment chapeau menace que ce
terrain est et ouest effectivement j ai
pas pensé mais c'était probablement mais
pas de casse préféré qu'on a fait ici
il est arrivé si magna enlever c'est
celui était nu pire comme en guérit
accès
le tout le monde qu'il écoutait au le
même le même commentaire c'est vraiment
surprenant lui les gens sont surpris oui
parce que encore ce jour une décennie
plus tard et on repense à l'aider on est
encore attaché à l'image en 3d 19 ans
qui crissent une volée alors gardien de
but bobby nadeau death marines coutume
mais même moi même ce marais d'yves le
5-1 amené dessous est un ami de jean
dans roues à magenta juan sas avait
écouté les play-offs au saguenay moi je
t'engage chicoutimi mais quand je le
détestais pieman je le déteste je ne
connaissais pas pantoute ne le chic un
jeu conçu par son ami puis quand ils
vont venir du mexique j'espère aller
prendre bien avec thé je vais faire des
affaires ensemble parce que c'est mon
ami mais l'anti fait que non mais non on
va aller on va les tuer un extrait chez
paul kane ont choisi un extrait qu'on
juge bon pigeon vole m s
extraits
[Musique]
quand tu fais ce move l'heure de dire je
continue parce que tout le monde
s'attend que je continue puis je fais ce
que je veux réellement fort combien de
temps parce que ces années là on dirait
quand même neuf au sens où tu sais où tu
as difficile d'être pris au sérieux dans
ce milieu là bah oui même encore
aujourd'hui
ouais tu le sais encore aujourd'hui
absolument syncope moi j'ai peut-être
que c'est juste parce que je sais pas je
te dire l'âge de bronze une question
ouais ça vous tue pendant ce raid
soutenir voire un shojo ouais ouais très
probablement moi mais c'est peut-être
parce que parce que je ne suis pas la
même façon que je te suggère m ok ouais
mais la plupart des gens si c'était plus
tu es sorti en même temps que le choix
de son fils a fêté un album de musique
risquerait giovine l'album ouais ouais
bon mois mais ben c'est un trip qui se
met tout le monde me comparer à lui
ouvertement grillé deux mois puis je me
rappelle mes premiers shows j'avais
dumont qui menaçait de la bia sa semaine
je mets mon bleu se bat avec moins
j'avais j'avais 2 2 plus passer par là
mais c'était quelque chose au début de
ma carrière c'est tough
il y avait aussi les fans finis petite
fille qui criait mais il y avait aussi
les fans à saguenay en moi à jamais face
à l'étranger coûte mais pas oui mais
voila fr est allé mais c'était pas
c'était plus du monde qui était
peut-être jaloux ou frustré après moi je
sais pas mais ces titres et étoffe un
petit boudin d'après ça mais ça s'est
calmé quoi mène dans l'apparence du
parfaite est un beau gars dont passé
patrick roy tous jouer au hockey tout
comme l'apparence du groupe pour qu'ils
tombent pour qui tout va bien puis il ya
quelque chose qui gosses certaines
personnes là dedans c'est comme si c'est
comme s'il fallait à falaise fallait
avoir un style un peu plus que sept
maëlys mais c'est ça les met les gens
savent même pas si on est tous humains
les gens s'invente et vente que les
riches pili billionaire ont pas de
problème climatique leur vie seront
belles non un tout le monde est pareil
tout le monde est pareil c'est parce que
juste eh oui peut-être que ton père
faisait de l'argent par contre tu étais
aussi partout en même temps tu avais pas
vraiment de titres au colorado à québec
qui avait été c'était sceptique quand
même là la vie d'un joueur de hockey
la vie de sa famille c'est tout ce site
offre main après ce petit puis tout cela
n'équivaut pas nécessairement de
l'argent l'argent est là pour payer
justement ce genre de ville le luxe
points mais moi j'ai vraiment une belle
enfance avec mon ami quand même jusqu'à
tac mais parra son temps mais ça va mes
parents sont séparés de stabilité plutôt
flou de la famille mais mon enfance
était quand même le fun pimont mon père
oui était parti souvent puis en vérité
mon pas raymond n'a pas eu de relation
vraiment jusqu'à l'âge de deux connectés
fait peut-être c'était parce qu'ils
étaient pas souvent la maison pts 2 kits
mais j'ai quand même une belle enfance
ma mère était magnifique et autres
génomes incroyable qu'ils nous aient
augmenté donné beaucoup beaucoup d'amour
on avait vraiment une famille title tête
idée magnifique but était d'aller au
mans par joueur qui les jeudis vendredis
samedis on en avait un
puis on était tous des passionnés dans
qui fait qu on ne pique à la radio
c'était magnifique adoré que la rade où
c'est sûr que peut-on te utd années
formatrices le français est plus
difficile un petit peu bougé tout un été
à l'école en anglais - quand je te
revenir qui est belge de la scène pas
tendre anglais aussi mais je me rattrape
le plus que je peux en parler avec ma
femme ma femme a passé près bien
français puis mais à mi temps tout en
français aussi du fait que de plus en
plus commença à capable de lire un des
livres en français si je te pas la pav
le 4-5 fait que je me je veux être plus
québécois ou francophones 2-2 lanxade
important oui mais oui elle est un
cadeau mes parents m'ont donné jeunes ce
de pouvoir parler de l'unss et c'est
magique aller dans le monde parle
anglais français
ma femme à part quatre langues
[Rires]
[Musique]
elle nous embarque un autre par dias qui
était extrêmement puissants aussi par la
force de la personne qu'on a reçu parce
que c'est déjà une personne qui est
capable de bien communiquer son métier
s'ils se creuser les bons enfants way
qui nous a parlé d'un million de la foi
qui est arrivé ici avec l'intention de
s'ouvrir
c'est pas tout le monde sait pas tout le
monde qu'on soit quelle intention de
s'ouvrir à 100 bourses un peu tout le
monde puis il ya certes un podcast qui
se passe des moments des changes
v - tous les porter tous les plus chers
et les podcasts mais il ya des fois on
tombe dans une zone aussi c'est vraiment
un échange c'est plus une entrevue ou
nous qui pose des questions puissante
retourne vers si c'est un échange chacun
parle avec son coeur
cephas titres allemands qui peut parler
de ce mois ci j'ai joué un petit peu
dans un bain de musique parce que je
faisais des bacs
puis c'est quand tu frappes le bac à
bonne note que la personne devant toi
frappe sa bonne note que vous faites des
harmonies puis vous le sentez on dirait
que la personne tu te crache son truc
d'ald en bouche c'est tellement c'est
pile dessus puis vous êtes les deux à
bono est en harmonie puis comme il
quelque chose qui se passe
il n'y a pas grand chose de plus
jouissif qui est de chanter en harmonie
juste
c'est ce que craint c'est aussi celle du
tronc la fin je me suis laissée au monal
comme ça il a enfin ajouté
non mais c'est vrai mais non mais les
gens parlent pas mais c'est chante en
harmonie des notes d'été des distances
et des fréquences exact que les
fréquences vibre une par dessus l'autre
m habite un quelqu'un qui dit que ses
notes ça c'est comme s'il y est l'inrena
prenait centre et nourri spi ça n'est
pas arrivé souvent d'être extrêmement
juste quand ça m'arrivait de faire les
bacs vraiment ça que je le sentais le
genre en actu emporter le vote l'entend
quand tu prends une harmonie vraiment
juste entre deux personnes ont plusieurs
personnes
une femme hockey de moins d'un mois une
note
mais donc moi je veux refaire une note
tout essayer d'aller chercher direct de
sucs et non mais je vais faire une offre
un certain jean
[Musique]
ah c'est bon c'est un peu émouvant moi
je suis demandé à voir avec vous un
orgasme à voir c'était jouissif wef est
qu avec des fois qu'elle en arrive dans
le pote de von arx et dans un podcast
puis en frappant un spot - où est ce que
promet nicolas parle en tout cas une cup
sûrement senti venir le chercher sur des
fois on frappe un spot où est ce qu'il
est et comme tout s'arrête au tour pions
on a plus l'impression qu'on est en
entrevue ou quoi que ce soit et pipi
avec avec rosalie c'est le fait ça quand
on s'y met à parler d'eux qu'est-ce
qu'on si on pouvait faire le ménage
de quoi entrer le ménage dans notre vie
puis puis des moments comme ça où est ce
que comme tout le monde on sent qu'on
grandit en même temps dans cette
discussion le ca arrive pas dans nos
vies mais ça fait elle tu vois qu'ils
allaient passer par des passes
difficiles
un pic a alors justement un peu comme
comme d'autres qu'on avancé mais plutôt
fait beaucoup d'introspection beaucoup
de changements de thérapie kahn le fait
depuis vous passez affectée si tu
t'améliores ta connaissance de soi c'est
ça se pressent à prix cassés posé
énormément de questions à la sagesse
pour repos pour son jeune âge quand même
assez surprenant
ouais mais oui en trois sets ont loupé
je me suis un extrait que quelqu'un
m'avait dit quelqu'un m'avait décrit
elle avait dit à me le dis aussi parler
plus à moi ok
qui sont ces hommes avaient demandé à
m'amener genre et ce qu'est ce reste
accroché à certains bobos de ta jeunesse
par telle impression cette définis tu
pilotes son reflex amateurs n'ont pas
vraiment réfléchi ça c'est un peu vrai
de dire que je restais tous ça mais
reste benmoussa mais rester mais je ne
suis pas quelqu'un qui ressasse beaucoup
le passé et les difficultés du passé moi
je suis pas mal d'autres choses même que
le passé et fès de flou et dont je me
souviens pas trop lent général mais mais
je vois ce que que suis beaucoup de gens
sympas tonnes de ressasser des vieilles
blessures du passé plutôt qu'aider si
plutôt que de les laisser à leeds et
papy stop et un peu s'est aussi laissé
aller avec elle les choses dans sa vie
qui nous apporte pas positifs mais aussi
les a laissé passer des vieux des
vieilles crottes connaissent le karaté
mais puis cette zone là on l'attend avec
rosalie mon latin aussi avec l'audio me
semble qu'on a eu des bons et des
buvettes
mais ça me connu d une bonne passe de
c'était deux podcasts extrêmement bons
et extrêmement plaisant pour nous puis
nikos qui ont été tantôt est ce que toi
tu cinq ans qu'on tombe dans une dans
une zone 2
comme tout le monde est commune aux
mêmes niveaux ndt
oui mais oui oui je le sens faites le en
fait mon au début parce que toi en plus
ce texte pas même quand derrière la
tétée juste dans le moment ouais je les
écoute les pots cassés
moi je dis que de toute façon en fait
moi j'étais enfant ne pas de casse à la
base fait facture oui et je les écoute
les podcasts houston puis
et puis walikale j'aimerais ça que tu me
dises des compliments qui peuvent se
poser des questions elle veut d'abord on
voit un extrait de rose et le bonheur
parce que parce que c'était un bon
casque au volant à peine d'être écoutés
peut-être découvert fait qu'au moyen
d'un extrait aussi on parle un des
sujets convient d'aborder les i
[Musique]
si vous pouviez vous désencombrer le de
quoi que ce soit dans le bâti
présentement en claquant des doigts le
sait fait pour vous qu'est ce que ce
serait si que ce soit une habitude ou
indépendance ou une personne même si
vous voulez le faire
donc oui j'ai fini mois nicole en propre
et amis c'est vraiment une bonne
question
moi j'ai l'impression que je le fais
quand même au jour le jour je vais me
poser question le fait qu en ce moment
ch quand même bien cc c'est pas de
réponse mais peinant équilibre si tu
travailles pour trop coûteux peu
tendance théâtre at remplir l'agenda
juste pour dire que tu travailles ou
quoi que ce soit c'est à dire quand même
c'est sûr que je suis sûr que le ch moi
je suis vraiment éparpillés entre québec
et montréal puis j'aime les deux places
mais la route est difficile de la beauté
l'ongle fakih suv fusionner puis avoir
un lieu et un mariage où tout se passe
ce serait cool que je te répondrais oui
c'est une question identitaire aussi je
pense question me dire est-ce que
falloir que je règle cette question à la
tête de mu et rescue remettons je me
vois montréal pour longtemps combien de
temps ce que je me vois maury est
capable d'enlever la charge émotionnelle
que j'aimais tant avec la ville de
québec inspq est capable de me dire plus
jamais tu as quitté le thé ou du moins
dans un futur rapproché
proment qui est capable d'un madame me
réveillant n'est en réponse à ce exact
puis deux puis me poser la question
quand je suis mettons en garde je prends
mon short à montréal quand j'ai pris
dans le trafic s'y cache prix des
réparations quand je prie le dans le
métro quand s'y jeter cap si je pouvais
mais ton parce que à chaque fois que
quelque chose de négatif arrive avec la
ville de montréal sam est en crise à
chaque fois je me dis qu'est ce que je
fais ici
s'il pouvait enlever son manteau ça pour
être que la réponse va venir
naturellement à toi tu sais j'ai
l'impression quand atteint un seuil
d'impatience comme signe l'aja proche de
sous oui mais c'est vraiment intéressant
même je vais enlever mon jaquette pour
ceux de la question identitaire le moi
je trouve c'est vrai j'ai oublié de
parler dans un micro je conseille
vraiment intéressant parce que c'est dit
on parle des relations on parle des
villes et tout mais par rapport à soi
même les attentes qu'on se met puis la
façon dont on dont on le traite nous
mêmes
j'ai souvent l'impression que c'est basé
sur tellement d'expérience qu'on a vécu
tellement de choses qu'on a fait du
passé qu'on traîne encore tg c'est
peut-être que je parle pour moi même et
on sait ce que je trouve intéressant de
me dire j'ai tendance à aa a coulé un
peu dans le béton la personnalité que
j'ai puisque je suis en jambes et moi
tout mon secondaire mes amis m'ont dit
que je t'ai tel genre de fille fac c'est
ce que je suis mais c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant de s'arrêter
dix ans plus tard deux à temps moi je me
définis encore comme une fille voilée
vrai chez même pas qu'est ce que je
pourrais donner comme exemple comme une
fille extravertie c'est comme si on
s'est tellement casey là dedans que tu
arrives à être convaincus que ces sommes
étaient puce
si autant que je sais que j'ai déjà été
vraiment très jalouse avec mon club
le cpie de même mais je porte encore la
culpabilité d'être une fille jalouse
alors que je suis puceau pourquoi on
fait sauter pour qu'on s'attache autant
à l'idée de ce qu'on est
il semble que ça nous empêche tellement
de cheminée salle haute est réconfortant
d'une certaine façon de savoir d'abord
leur père par rapport à qu'est-ce que tu
es tu de pouvoir mettre une étiquette de
mettre une étiquette sur des trucs qui
est quelque chose de réconfortant à la
demande qui de plus en plus du moins
j'essaie de le faire de moins en moins
je sais des épices et des bd construit
qui le temps déjà menés l'été la façon
que j'ai été élevé la façon mettons la
façon que je vois un couple le plus du
para du monde comme l'autre on parle à
joe white si tu parles est un gars comme
j'attends roi pelé de parts on copie
dudit crise il n'y a pas la même
étiquette que j'aurais mis sur le mien
mais il ya tout là moins bien il a aussi
battu le besoin d'avoir ce est ce que
j'ai besoin
je suis comme dit moi je peux m'en le
contraire au sol ont lâché le contraire
de toi apparemment des antiquaires est
ce que je suis vraiment introverti
lorsque les on dirait que je me dis on
embauche introverti fake je prends pas
part à aix y z d'activité maintenant est
ce qui est des activités que je me
bloque parce que je me dis j'aimerais
pas ça parce que je suis un introverti
c'est très probablement beaucoup de fois
je dois rester chez nous à misano ce
j'aime pas ça parce que jamais mais ce
puits mais c'est pas la même chose à
chaque fois c'est pas les mêmes gens qui
vont être là pour le même trip tipi les
fois où est-ce qu'ils émettront j'estime
qu'on vient d'aller en place ça arrive
rarement que je me laisse convaincre
d'aller à une plastie mais des fois que
ça arrivait j'ai eu vraiment du fun puis
c'est vrai que des fois que je partis de
bonne heure mais au pire c'est mais on
n'écoute pas mettre mes donc tu mets pas
dans l'archétype que tu penses que tu es
réellement indépendant l'identité qui
donne à toi même passer ça c'est
réconfortant les étiquettes mais en même
temps c'est un peu contraignant ça peut
devenir un carcan de dire c'est même
juste pour l'identité sexuelle j'étais
tout le temps oui terreau facture est
fermé aux possibilités jusqu'à ce que tu
réalises que oh ben non ça ce petit je
pense qu'il faut juste pas voir ça comme
si c'étaient vraiment des murs fermé sur
toi tu peux ouvrir les fenêtres leur
garde à l'extérieur pilote peut-être que
ça m'intéresserait finalement pis je
pense que c'est une belle façon de faire
est en constante évolution tout à fait
tout à fait puis de plus en plus j'ai
l'impression que que c'est qui ce
questionnement le sangle prendre de
l'ampleur dans mettons on est un peu
plus tôt avait dans notre génération
mais pression que aucune espèce de désir
de d'ouvrir les fenêtres comme tu as une
d'illustrer laitiers ce désir collectif
de fort hare voyons ce que nos parents
nous ont ainsi parce que parce que si tu
vraiment se situe vraiment ce
qu'estiment les portugais depuis ici
[ __ ] ce cas-ci imputant ce que c'était
vraiment puis on en parlait ce matin de
chemin avec jesse sur le podcast hier
on leur su par rapport à peu par rapport
en lien avec la parade la pride
il y aurait retiré puis il ya plein de
monde qui vont apparaître pas parce
qu'ils sont dans des diversité sexuelle
juste parce qu'ils veulent embrasser le
choix c'est le choix de france qui tue
le choix de pas avoir de restriction de
tous les niveaux puis je trouve quand
que je trouve que c'est une belle époque
des dans laquelle on vit présentement à
ben certain niveau c'est sûr qu'à
d'autres encore c'est pas si mal mais à
ce niveau loin
[Musique]
and back
qu'est ce que tu voulais dire à annuler
and back et nicole ce que je vais te
demander ces prix des trophées le
podcast sans trop se poser de questions
pareil on sait pas exactement que ce
qu'on fait novice nommé t on ne s'est
pas assis pis on s'est dit nice 6e
on vient ici en parler dans un micro et
on invite qui on dit qu'on veut puis on
parle naturellement on s'envoie dans les
zones qui ne sont naturels et d'attica
sait pas plus
réfléchissez pas plus ou moins tu as les
excuses c'est ce message que savoir
qu'est ce qui fait qu est ce qui fait
que toi mettons tout abonné aux
pitchouns puisqu'elle ne te décider
suivre le podcast en fait plutôt qu'un
nom plutôt que d'autres ensuite
automatiquement
c'est vraiment difficile à expliquer
mais
moi en fait je me suis abonnée au pq et
parce que à un moment donné c'est
quasiment rendu addictif en fait
l'espace qu'elle manège en avait plus
assez d'une fois par semaine
j'ai réalisé que sur peyton je pouvais
en écouter comme deux l'achat depuis
neuf mois c'est aussi que je travaillais
la fin de semaine je faisais des longues
journées qui se voulait sortir les
samedis comme tel super g aliments
vivants moi en plus j'ai écouté la fin
de semaine pendant que je travaillais je
n'ai vraiment pas productif mais
d'escadron maman maman fait pour les
écouter les podcasts des faux j'en
écoutais plus mais moi je pense en fait
la force de votre pas de casse et c'est
que c'est quand même grand public en
fait si justement vous receviez on aime
attendre plus activités on est comme
deux filles le matin vers 6h gaulle non
c'est pour ça que je faisais mais c'est
juste qu'ils étaient vous serez plein de
monde appelait milieux différents
festivals être pas d'un échec sauter
aussi
et puis en fait moi je trouve ça c'est
vraiment super bowl casse pour commencer
on en écoute beaucoup de monde sait à
qui j'ai parlé qui écoutent pas vraiment
de podcasts mais ce sera ensuite discuté
deux trois épisodes mais tant pis je
pense je pense que c'est la force de ce
podcast locity c'est que ça vient pis
moi même mais même ça a été mon collègue
- avant vous autres j'en écoutais saviez
démocratiser l'époque que j'ai une
question pour toi même des fat attention
à nos styles questions posées si on
devait améliorer quelque chose pour 2010
un ca fait le podcast qu'est ce qu'on
aurait amélioré mais la plus largement
kenkel pin coll je laisse le temps du
possible mais on écrivait les
commentaires constructifs dans les dents
les la déception du podcast parce que on
veut s'améliorer on veut s'améliorer
puis on est ouvert à toutes les
propositions d'amélioration possible
seulement si vous s'il ya quelque chose
qui est vous cherchez aussi si vous
voulez une dire pourquoi vous écouter
sans filtre dans les commentaires c'est
s'est aussi apprécié mais n'hésitez pas
si vous allez commentaires constructifs
définitivement surtout pour 2020 comment
d'un mot d'un bon pied
les deux premiers sont déjà tournés fait
qu'on peut pas salir et à ce niveau là
ça fait ce qui se met même en quelques
mois j'ai une idée
la tension monte à la vraie vie humaine
oui mais c'est pas ça fait cette épice
sa phase avec plusieurs podcast en fait
le mot je trouve mais qui en fait
surtout avec jon rubinstein
mais ce que admettons c'est celle
expliquent-ils mais spa sculpter votre
votre opinion revient à travailler n'est
pas à son endroit les différents podcast
on parle de dégâts nice avec tout les
invités clame admettons
si on parle des théories du complot
ouais c'est aussi votre point de vue là
dessus c'est votre point de vue est
clair
puis ce je pense que ça fait que s'y met
on vous recevez quelqu'un qui en parle
de tout de ce genre de sujet lui je
pense que peut-être confort pour assez
loin comme victor y est arrivé si vite
rattrapé puis à savè qu'est ce qu'on
pensait théorie du complot puis à
voulait pas trop aborder ce sujet là
parce qu'il savait qu'on était déjà en
désaccord avec la plupart théorie du
complot mais en même temps si c'est
normal parce que je peux toujours pas
non plus que vous changé votre façon de
penser si c'est vous autres qui fait le
podcast réclamant c'est vous autres qui
ont peut pas être toujours parfaitement
d'accord avec tous nos invités parce
qu'on serait dit mais je pense qu'on a
une bonne dynamique par rapport à soi
tout et tout est plus celui que votre
challenge et l'idée de l'inviter me dois
être plus celui qui va être ouvert à
recevoir un peu plus intransigeants que
tous allez pouvoir le voir dans le
podcast s'en vient avec jérémy demain
est ce que moi je suis beaucoup plus
ouverts à savoir que jérémy à dire que
toi mais c'est tout à fait correct qu'on
a surtout que moi je mettais tout
informe plus que moi avant les podcasts
fait plus de recherche que moi sur les
invités effectué déjà j'avais dit que
j'étais servait déjà cogité 7,6
informations l'homme âgé des reçus au
moment où ce que je dis reçus par un
podcast
mais effectivement nous en faire
confirmer je pense que je pense que tu
compléter cette façon là c'est bon aussi
je pense qu'on se complète bien parce
qu'on ne conviennent que maudit th il
est mieux de dire oui
la clé du succès merci me poserai le dos
maintenant à voir ce que big lots manie
modique et sarah meier sans péage sais
pas mais ph à moi je pense que moi je
pense qu est ce qu est ce qui serait bon
le podcast quoi que je fasse au débat
abordé ce 8e enfin de podcasts parce que
le froid y aller parce qu'on est le
parti du sud usa vient on à une
réservation resto mais je tiens à dire
premièrement que ce serait un excellent
candidat d'occupation double mais plus
largement cause des pectoraux mois à
cause des pectoraux 1 semaine seule
chypre est plutôt raconter une petite
anecdote avant constitue une autre
anecdote daudet on parle beaucoup d'eau
dans ce podcast le stop normal parce que
je les fais c'est une expérience quand
même la green gym mais on était dans le
chalet à tremblant avec les deux autres
coupes finaliste gc - était avec les
deux autres coupes donc adamo alex pis
joanis andric connecter les émissions
puis la première dès que j'ai c'est mon
humour est ce que on s'est dit ok je
pense qu'on est c'est quelque chose de
plus que justin coupe dodge
c'était à nos salles ngogang était une
île à côté de ben ali - ce qu'on est
allé en beta excentrique pigeon annie
autre que puis on excès les émissions
puis en est la première on s'est
approchés physiquement puisque et
comment on s'est approché on s'est collé
c'est un moment ultra intense dans nos
têtes on écoute les émissions puis après
la pause
est-ce que jesse coulera pour les
pectoraux de pascal ou groupe le cdj et
storm qui disent nous c'est un moment
charnière dans notre relation est ce
qu'on s'est finalement approché c'est
jay du stand en voix off qui parle de
mes pectoraux cher
même salle tellement pas de sens espoirs
reflet juste de la situation en allant
vraiment pas mais quand tu le vois que
de l'intérieur que peu importe
j'espère que tu feras ton pseudo pouvoir
ressentir matin des 85 % de chances que
tu le fasses pas mais fait que ça veut
dire 15% tandis que tu le fasses
j'imagine que alors où on se parle
cinq heures après la conversion des
rangées à 20% de chance non mais j'avoue
je dois avouer une chose j'ai toujours
été absolument fermer le des fraudes et
mais l'objectif c'est terrible je me dis
ça comme une expérience humaine
l'expérience ce genre vraiment
extraordinaire extraordinaire que ça de
le changer grandi puis je me dis ce qui
est quand même positif le apprécié le
négatif j'ai envie de mettre ma vie sur
pause professionnellement pendant les
vacances des vacances gîtes eu envie
j'ai très envie d'avoir mon image dans
les mains déjà qu'ils qui évidemment son
lot pour m'exploiter mais pour faire un
show qui pose quand le droit de twister
mon image al amana bijoux qu indique
enfin qu'il utilise dans tous les cas tu
es pas un gosse je pense que je n'irai
jamais un entrevue des restes est-il
déjà tout est prêt pour ce ouais tu
ferais des études montrant les
situations au cuir est jamais parlé dans
le dos de quelqu'un de tellement entendu
parler dans doute quelqu'un etc je me
mettrai les pieds les plus beaux jamais
en handball dans d'autres quelqu'un crs
jean tatillon des fois on fait des
blagues sur du monde lamy shearer pas
entendu parler négativement genre
viscéralement de quelqu'un qui fait que
tu le ferais pas danseur fait que le
monde devrait redire à damas où il
mettait les pieds dans tous les domaines
y gagnerait
ouais mais j'aurais peur d'être passé
fort parce que logiquement en fait je
pense que c'est ça ma plus grande part
j'aurais pas de virer fou qui le monde
vire fou la preuve les jeunes je pense
que j'aurai par décret à qui j'avais
peur je pense je pense pas je suis juste
spécialement insécure ou spécialement
fragile me disent que je parlais tantôt
mettons que que yacine journée de marche
des fois tu puisses assez drôle parce
que ça m'arrive est pas parce qu un
sentiment nouveau dans ma vie ces
phénomènes de tout allait bien dans les
biens et une ligne droite c'est logique
et ce comme nouveau que des fois il faut
profiter comme nouveau des fois je vois
pas bien pis j'aurais pas d'être comme
tomber dans un pattern que je peux
vraiment pas bien alors je comprends
très bref fait que le chedi je te dirai
je suis ferme et 85 pour ça je ferme à
85 % à 15 % de positivisme
si vous voulez que john hayes sur rodez
commenté dans la vidéo commentée sur le
podcast dans le fond puis on va gérer ce
rendu la fiq man c'était un 2019 que
j'ai adoré des années le plus mouvementé
toute ma vie mais aussi mensah a été
recueillie à travers - tout ça a été
aussi rocailleux dans
professionnellement que personnellement
sur tout personnel surtout
personnellement je peux leur parler du
second de métier il ya eu iman tu es une
fille pendant 5 apparaît moins pis ça
faisait cinq ans que vous connaissez est
celle d'isaac ont aidés nous travaillons
ensemble qu'on était dans mon travail
encore sans d'ailleurs maîtrise et un
gros bouleversement passé n'est pour
dire à quel point c'est un gros
bouleversement
c'est quelqu'un que moi même j'avais
dans ma vie oui c'est ça c'est quelqu'un
que moi même dans la vie puisque leurs
qualités on est indissociable watch et
ce pendant plusieurs années on était
puis
anne est fusionnelle indissociables
parce qu'on travaille ensemble on
habitait ensemble de tout ensemble fakty
veut pas du jour au lendemain se
retrouver au pied je pense que je pense
que sur le plan personnel ça a été
l'année la plus dure pour moi il était
le fait ça paraissait pas un podcast
mais je n'ai pas très bien
les botteurs bien pis pour la préfère ma
vie j'ai pas celui qui en parlent le
plus non plus de métier c'est drôle
parce que tu es quand on a commencé en
podcast on s'est dit que je fais ce que
j'aime ce métier tu étais mon meilleur
ami puis on est super proche mais je
sais pas pourquoi
et certaines choses que je serais à
l'aise a parlé de mon plus proche que
moi 1 - prochains mois mais c'est pas
parce que on se connaît depuis trop
longtemps je sais pas pourquoi on a
besoin c'est pourquoi ses besoins mais
attaquer j'aspire pas peut-être que je
n'aspire pas ça non plus mais en même
temps je sais pas moi la première fois
on rappelle que quand tu m'as dit la
première fois que ça allait moyens on
est allé chercher cette tv le chez nous
moi je m'attendais à rien [ __ ] ma came
dit ouais mais ça va moyen quand même je
voulais pas me dire surtout bien mieux
de comme ça qu'on échoue en train
d'amener la tv ouais mais el manar mais
je comprends mais mais c'est ce qui
était encore à ce jour justement ça vaut
mais ccc faut qu'ils mènent ces fois
qu'ils faut qu'ils manient des sabres en
la moitié du temps des relations poteau
remise d'une relation peut-être mais je
convaincu que tous les bouleversements
sont petits citoyens que ce déménagement
c'est aussi moi c'est ceux ci vouloir t
que la france peut rediriger corriger ma
carrière pourtant j'aime ce que je fais
j'aime ce faire de musique puis je me
plains poppy puis en fait et j'en pense
à ça parce que ce n'est pas le cas ça
s'est passé avec adamo qui j 7
quand j'ai tourné hier
comme tony gamme qui se calculent toi
mais qui sortira en france et j'ai eu
l'air de c'est quand même fou qui est
incroyable que puis je pense qu'il faut
que je les réalise caisse quand même
fois king incroyable de chances de
gagner ma vie en musique
puis-je à quelqu'un quand je réalise que
je participe de 10mn moi je pense que je
vais commencer à tirer non pas parce
qu'on se sait qu'on tient là un quartier
woippy dj set ça mais je mets ça m'a
frappé moi-même avec quel point des fois
je suis petit j'ai comme un excès
d'humilité ou un exceed si j'essaie tout
fait de la musique ses hôtes lui voulait
que j'en parle qu'il est au lieu que je
fasse hu à ses hôtes puis je fais si
j'avais su que j'étais le projet puis
c'est vraiment le fun jusqu'à moi je
fais de la musique le pitch
ce jeu fait gelé shopi entre gens là
parlent de manac et comme je dise mais
seule la main noire ses 16 comme comme
ça parce que c'est pas des produits
créatifs à twente belge est né le projet
créatif photophone mais oui oui encore à
ce jour super mimi beals en faisant même
ce sésame james appareils puis c'est
l'fun pigeât même site révolutionne pas
la musique jouée pour le monde qui ont
du plaisir qu'ils ont retrouvé d'en face
puis qui danse c'est quand même
gratifiant parce que tu répondes bonheur
l'hymen répandu bonheur même moi même au
cégep
j'étudiais musique plus pratiqué genre
six ans par jour puis j'ai vraiment eu
une espèce de questionnements
existentiels de ce que je fais ça sert à
quelque chose
très utile dans société georgy sujet
dessus une pertinence
parce que si j'avais spi sujet de cette
introspection réflexion de sept cas est
le trait cherche loge de sortir dix ans
non ce sera autre chose je pense pas
l'atpu vivent une vie hamza ben moi
j'aime ça mettez en réalité dans le le
grand dans la société outils dans le
green slim of kings je sers à rien je
pense pas que j'aurais dû plus vaste
mais les hormones moi j'ai vraiment la
conviction que ce soit musique théâtre
cinéma littérature gérant la conviction
c'est essentiel à la halle à l'humain à
la société puis si je faisais pas opter
et puis je retire quand même
satisfaction à dire je n'aime pas la
musique mais je répondis bona
aujourd'hui mon devoir rentrer chez eux
heureux ils ont passé une belle soirée
une belle journée
ils vont en parler à leurs amis ont
derrière les buts el bey notamment
iphone puis segrate dans le fond je
pense faut que je sois plus
reconnaissants et plus que je réalise
plus la chasse puis aussi le cas quelle
posture beau métier que je sais ta
résolution 2020 résolution 2020 mais ça
veut pas dire que je porte et rediriger
après ma ma pratique en guillemets vers
des projets plus créatifs puis une chose
que je trouve le long de réclamations de
psy mais on dirait que l'eau est un peu
en mode dédoublement personnalité parce
que je viens sur le podcast
puis le jeune homme le podcast ont la
pression gens de chez nous je fais de la
musique puis chez les shows mais les
gens qui ne connaissent pas le
podcasting relais pour le podcast puis
les gens qui me voient faire de la
musique c'est pratiquement uniquement
les gens qui sont présents le soir chez
des shows ouais
sinon il est passé en d'autres qui
explique que chez des musiques épicées
des moments qui ça va parce que je suis
un show oui c'est le fun et demain qui
m'appelle pas c'est qu'il gueule qui a
chanté à pau
charbaji chante de tounsi gens qui
touchent 10 mme banon mais n'empêche que
c'est pas des moments et des moments
uniques que du crime - famille comme
union avec avec le public messin moment
fm à un moment qui s'évapore apprécié
c'est en même temps un homme est mort
dix dates it may mais je pense que
j'aimerais sur plus me mettre de l'avant
dans l'univers des intérêts web
musicalement aussi pour que comme soit
pas juste qu'il ait pas de casse mais je
suis le gars quel est ton chemin vers
l'influencent par la haute influence et
d'avancer grandement en forêt juste que
tu commences à faire des vidéos mais
c'est ça que je joue de la guitare
exactement sécurité du bac est mal
suivait deux d'une plante sur instagram
puis vous allez voir des vidéos de
l'électeur 2020
je veux montrer que j'ai je pense
puy-de-dôme à 10h le soutien rn2 monde
sauf mike il va faire juste des cover de
bas nylon sur sa page j'espère faut
effectivement devant hélène par la
babylone billy a déjà fait une entrevue
avec je pense robert puis le lit pose
des questions genre des trucs mais
l'autre des références aux années 90
puis à la niche permet dans 90 il le
fait qu'aucune même même plutôt que ce
pas que l'âge d'or 17 à dégainer genre
2001 mémoire fethi belaid marne van
halen sait plus à qui jean et ivan lendl
non juste posé qui il a apprécié les
réseaux sociaux mais les fans de
vanilline se sont enflammés pleure un
commentaire très voyant qu'elle sait pas
ce qu'il en est l'inde le népal est
classique la musique se plaint lui ai
dit mané la fête des jards ce café
segrate pige or je pense que ce qu'on
fait c'est greenpeace pas grave puis
georges chacun fait son truc
pis genre tout mon école ici là la
semaine risque
on va rapper bientôt à lille mais la
semaine voici que tout c'est tout ça
faisait même infini qui est pas sorti
d'album tous m'ont sorti un album puis
pendant une semaine et est numéro un sur
itunes puis c'est la même semaine que
oui
tabarnak et blanc domaine
et chanter du country avant l éclatement
s'amuse et thonon gaillard
télé séries2 c'était le swift est il a
sorti son album la même semaine plus la
semaine passe qui était le second album
tout la veine numéro un il sur twitter
je suis tombé sur un post du monde
faisait tout le ramasser toutes les
tweets défend d'être le joueur faisait
chaque fois des forts que tout ces
contrats portent tous et comme le bnd
légendaire tout les fans attendent l
album depuis des années s'est hâté le
sud-darfour de son cinquième album en
six ans c'est pourquoi c'est pas lui qui
numéro un c'est qui ce tour ça veut tout
dire impossible et que c'est bon l'autre
sur ses commentaires
surtout nous faut combattre ouais parce
que c'est le parti de dieu cf commence à
être chaud des joueurs c'est fait merci
merci à l'infini à toutes les les autres
stone s'intéresse à sa merci
on vous souhaite de la santé de l'amour
de bien entourer le prend soin des gens
que vous aimez du succès dans vos études
d'autres petits tout tenter d'harmoniser
les jouets géants terminé vous allez
joueur peut on vous promet un 2020
tout aussi bon sinon meilleur que 2010
9e
c'est la galère